we are just seven months away from the
midterm elections they'll be upon us
very quickly the Biden White House is in
one crisis after another and yet again
today a key inflation gauge just set
another 40-year high this impacts every
single American every American household
a whopping 6.4 percent increase and
according to Bloomberg News the average
American family now can expect to spend
five thousand two hundred dollars more
this year or 433 dollars more each month
on the exact same items they bought one
year ago already one out of every five
workers in this country is now running
out of money before payday that number
is expected to get much worse and in
Biden's economy it is especially worse
and burdensome and a hardship for the
poor in the middle class in this country
at the core of these economic woes
record high after record high gas prices
and tonight the American people just
know who to blame they say yeah it's Joe
Biden his policies or the nor the number
one cause for the increase in fuel costs
which means that's more to heat and cool
our homes and more we pay at every store
that we go to this poll conducted by
Quinnipiac now here's the news flash for
Democrats ahead of the midterms American
people guess what they have figured it
out new green deal socialism's not going
to work ever and on the campaign Trail
it was your candidate Joe Biden vowing
to end fossil fuels this was the
predictable result and during his very
first week in office he banned Drilling
in Anwar we have such vast resources we
could have cheap energy for every
American you ban new exploration and
auctions on federal lands he killed the
Keystone XL pipeline the Alberta Premier
said if they finished it it would have
been done by now uh we would have nine
hundred thousand uh barrels of oil at of
a day flowing into this country from
Canada last month the administration
they paused all new leases on oil and
gas because of climate change what a
surprise U.S gas prices predictably are
higher than ever in fact costs have been
rising every single month since Joe
Biden took office Vladimir Putin did not
cause that Joe Biden new green deal
radical socialism caused it but
according to him Vladimir Putin and kova
19 are to blame for his woes well if
it's covered Why didn't it happen under
Trump take a look
problem we're facing with gas prices has
two Roots first the pandemic
when covet struck demand for oil
plummeted so production slowed down
worldwide
is because of the strength and the speed
of our recovery demand for oil shot back
up much faster than the supply
that's why the cost of gas began to rise
last year
the second route is Vladimir Putin the
start of this year gas was about three
dollars and thirty cents a gallon today
it's about averaging 420 422 is higher
in many states
nearly a dollar more in less than three
months
the reason for that is because of
Putin's War
blame Trump blame covet blame Putin
blame everybody no it's your policies
economic and energy policies Joe the
causes and Biden apparently had trouble
opening his eyes squinting into the
light it's kind of like when he whispers
or he says come on man what are you a
junkie we owe these truths to be
self-evident all men and women are
created equal endowed by oh oh the the
thing you know the thing God the creator
of everything anyway any Outline by the
way his solutions for the oil and gas
crisis he caused now the first is a
political Ploy that does very little to
lower costs and puts our national
security at risk and for the next six
months Joe will deplete America's
strategic strategic preserves by
releasing a million barrels of oil a day
that's nothing this Reserve by the way
is meant for National Security
emergencies not for Joe's political
Advantage going into a midterm and not
the rising gas prices either it is the
only a short-term Band-Aid that will do
nothing to significantly reduce costs it
doesn't get to the underlying problem
doesn't get to the root cause and it
conveniently expires on Election Day
moments ago our very own Chad program
well he caught up with the spiritual
leader of the democratic party's climate
alarmist religious cult that of course
is the author of the new green deal
socialism and that's congresswoman
ocasio-cortez to see what she thinks
about Biden's new plan let's take a look
while the president is making a decision
to release some strategic reserves to
release some of the pressure on pricing
I think a lot of these fossil fuel and
oil and gas companies also need to do
their part and we have to understand
that sometimes it's about taking a
smaller profit margin
if we're going to be really engaged in
all of this together particularly in the
response should it be refilled after
they drain this portion of the sprawl
you know I think we need to take a look
at the proportion of what is uh is is
being used but ultimately we really do
need to be investing in Renewables
here we go which brings us to Biden's
second solution lower gas prices he now
wants Congress to slap oil and gas
companies with fines if they don't drill
on already approved Federal leases we've
already told you all about this a
terrible plan we'll give you two reasons
why one any fine guess what that'll get
passed on to you the consumer which
means gas prices will even go higher and
two oil leases they are provided
pre-exploration many and most of these
unused leases don't have enough oil or
gas that can be extracted that's why
they're not using them now if you think
that's bad Biden's next solution well to
Rising gas prices that's even worse take
a listen
ultimately we in the whole world need to
reduce our dependence on fossil fuels
altogether we need to choose long-term
security over energy and climate
vulnerability we need to double down on
our commitment to clean energy and
tackling the climate crisis under my
plan which is before the Congress now we
can take advantage of the next
generation of electric vehicles
that a typical driver will save about
eighty dollars a month from not having
to pay gas at the pump
if your home is powered by safer cheaper
cleaner electricity like solar or heat
pumps you can save about five hundred
dollars a month on average
what's up with the eyes you can save
eighty dollars a month all right if you
just go out and buy a sixty thousand
dollar electric car and guess what in 62
years you can recoup your investment
according to speaker Nancy Pelosi it's a
small price to pay while the green New
Deal religious climate cult Warriors and
her party are out to save the planet
take a look
we cannot allow the fossil fuel industry
to use this as an excuse to reverse
everything we're doing to save the
planet
one of the things I think that the
president may say I don't have this as a
fact is that we will use the defense
production act to speed up uh
diversification uh so that we're not so
dependent on oil
another cognitive train wreck when you
think Democrats Democrats can't get any
more out of touch with all of this or
any more inept think again I present to
you vice president Kamala Harris giving
a speech about Jamaica now you got to
listen every word to really get this pay
close attention
just as it has been in the United States
for Jamaica one of the issues that has
been presented as an issue that is
economic in the way of its impact has
been the pandemic
So to that end we are announcing today
also that we will assist Jamaica in
covid recovery by assisting in terms of
the recovery efforts in Jamaica that
have been essential to I believe what is
necessary to strengthen not only uh the
the issue of Public Health but also the
economy
I needed an interpreter anyway the
midterms of fast approaching there are
no lifelines for this Democratic radical
new green deal Socialist Party the
economy is poised sadly to get worse
high gas prices sadly they're not going
away war in in Europe is Raging sadly it
doesn't seem to be coming to an end soon
a southern border take a look it's now
bracing for another massive Surge and
yes violent crime is spiking out of
control thanks to Democrats and their
defund dismantle uh police and no bail
insanity and your president your vice
president and even your speaker are
visibly incompetent now multiple new
polls have Biden at all-time lows it and
according to msdnc's Chucky Todd the
Democrats are in for a full shellacking
it's rare that I quote this usual idiot
he got it right for once
the current round track in our poll is
71 percent what's really striking is
third straight pull where the direction
of the country has been above 70 percent
it's only been one other time we've had
that in our poll it is not a good time
and if you have 71 forget look 65 wrong
track is a bad number 71 that's why it
is in the shellacking category you've
got three essentially three numbers here
that all Point into dangerous territory
for the Democrats in the incumbent party
presidential job rating at 40 percent
wrong track over 70 percent and the
Republicans leading in the generic
ballot
not a good time
none of these Sunday hosts are like well
the great Tim russson and he was great
now vote like your country depends on it
because if Democrats maintain power your
life's only going to get worse hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else